welcome to the 30th annual National
Geographic V let's meet your 10
finalists from Texas thirteen-year-old
Neha Jenga is a winner of the 2016
Scripps National Spelling Bee when he's
not studying geography he enjoys playing
football and video games with friends
from California 13-year old van cut Ron
Jun plays the piano and has been
competing in both his school and state
beast since 2015 from Arizona
thirteen-year-old gayatri Kimmel has
been snorkeling in Hawaii when she's
back in the lower 48
she loves listening to music and reading
from Ohio
thirteen-year-old socket potaraju has
won the Ohio State beef three years in a
row
he's also quite the outdoorsman he loves
playing tennis and exploring nature from
New Jersey thirteen year old anushka
booty coat has been playing violin since
the young age of seven she's also an
avid reader and plans on writing a novel
about an explorer from Massachusetts 11
year old a trio mallanna is an
accomplished athlete he plays cricket
soccer and swims from Oregon 13-year old
Ashwin Sivakumar is a composer and
birder he's even spent time
bird-watching while traveling through
Costa Rica from Georgia
fourteen-year-old Vishal surrett II
counts Hawaii among his coolest
destinations and loves playing
basketball and running cross-country
from North Carolina 14 year old Jonathan
song plays golf and is on a competitive
robotics team when he's not tearing it
up on the course he loves traveling he's
made it all the way to China and finally
from New Hampshire 14 year old Sean
Chang enjoys speedcubing traveling and
fishing a competitor in all areas he
also loves to play high-level soccer
here they are the 2018 National
Geographic Bee finalists and now your
host journalist humorist and Emmy
award-winning writer mo
well hello everyone I am thrilled to be
back in Washington DC hosting the
National Geographic Bee which turns 30
this year which means it's only two
years older than I am
this year 2.6 million students competed
in their school Geographic bees 54 top
geographers from each state and u.s.
territory earned the right to compete
this week and after a series of
preliminary rounds 10 extremely worthy
finalists made it to this stage today
one of these bright minds will earn a
fifty thousand dollar scholarship and
the title of National Geographic Bee
champion are you ready to begin let's
get started the first seven rounds will
focus on u.s. geography this first round
will require spoken answers only I'm
going to ask each of you a question
about a capital city in the United
States a photo related to your question
will appear on your monitor you will be
asked to name the city and state that
it's in these questions are worth one
point you will have 12 seconds to answer
students are you ready they're ready
here we go
Nihar we begin with you here is the
first question this state capital on the
Pearl River was named after a president
of the United States named this city and
state Jackson Mississippi that is
correct for one point vane cut home to
the Mark Twain House and museum this
state capitol is north of the Long
Island Sound named this city and state
Hartford Connecticut that is correct
gayatri located in the Central Valley
this state capitol was the western
terminus for both the Pony Express and
the first transcontinental railroad
named this city and state
Sacramento California you got it socket
this state capital is northwest of
Daniel Boone National Forest and is
located in the bluegrass region named
this city and state Frankfort Kentucky
that is right
a new sky this state capital is located
near both the big belt mountains and the
source of the Missouri River named this
city and state Helena Montana that is
correct
a TRAI founded by the French this state
capital is located 150 miles upstream
from the Mississippi River Delta named
this city and state Baton Rouge
Louisiana that is correct
Ashwin located on the Hudson River this
state capital was an active trading post
in the 1600s named this city and state
Albany New York you got it vishal
located about 20 miles from the Platte
River this state Capitol building is
topped by a nearly 20 foot statue of a
farmer named this city and state Lincoln
Nebraska Lincoln Nebraska is correct
Jonathan located on the eastern edge of
the Sierra Nevada this State Capitol
experienced a silver rush in the 1850s
named this city and state Carson City
Nevada
that is right Sean this state capitol is
east of the Ouachita Mountains and is
home to the William J Clinton
Presidential Library named this city and
state Oklahoma City Oklahoma
I'm sorry the answer was Little Rock
Arkansas and we are off and running at
the 2018 National Geographic Bee
these ten gifted finalists are competing
for $85,000 in college scholarships
today's champion will win fifty thousand
of it along with a lifetime membership
to the National Geographic Society and a
Lindblad expedition to the Galapagos
Islands aboard the National Geographic
endeavor to second place will earn a
$25,000 scholarship and $10,000 goes to
the third place finisher sounds pretty
good right I'd say so for round two
you'll use your stylus and tablets
everyone answers this next question at
the same time this question is worth one
point and you'll have 12 seconds to
write your answer national parks have
been called America's greatest idea and
yet these and other public lands face
serious threats National Geographic is
dedicated to furthering our
understanding of these critical
ecosystems and inspiring action to
protect them take a look at your
monitors Yellowstone National Park is a
geological and ecological wonder it was
the world's first national park and
covers nearly 3,500 square miles but
it's ecosystem is threatened by activity
outside its borders while it is best
known for its bison bears and wolves the
parks most abundant large mammal is the
elk whose migration paths reach well
beyond Yellowstone's boundaries and here
is your question
elk once roamed most to the United
States but hunting and loss of habitat
reduced to their range to the area of
what mountain range that includes
Yellowstone National Park and that
stretches from New Mexico to British
Columbia you will have 12 seconds to
write down your answer
time's up let's see what you wrote and
surprise surprise for one point the
correct answer is Rocky Mountains
ten for ten nicely done you can now put
down your stylus because round three
will require spoken answers only I'm
going to ask each of you question that
will test your knowledge of revered
places in the United States when it's
your turn a photo related to your
question will appear on your monitor
Nihar we begin with you here is your
question sacred to many Alaskans this
mountain was known by the early a
sebastian people as the tall one and it
may have been central to their creation
story named this mountain mount denali
or mount mckinley well done denali is
correct for one point and mount mckinley
was also acceptable thank you van cut
Thornhill Chappell blends into the
surrounding woods giving visitors a
sense that they are seated in the forest
itself the chapel is located in what
physiographic region that covers much of
northern Arkansas and southern Missouri
the Ozark plateau the Ozark plateau is
correct
Gayatri
Big Sur a scenic region along the
California coast has long attracted
Native Americans Hermits and artists
this region stretches from
carmel-by-the-sea to San Simeon along
what mountain range the Sierra Nevada
I'm sorry we were looking for Santa
Lucia sake the city of Nauvoo attracts
visitors due to its historic importance
as the home of the Latter day Saints
from 1839 to 1846 before they traveled
west to the Great Salt Lake neva is
located upstream from Quincy on what
River the Mississippi River that is
correct
anooshka this famous gospel choir
performs all over the world sharing the
joy of faith through music the choir
shares its name with a large
neighborhood in Upper Manhattan that is
a center of african-american culture
named this neighborhood Harlem Harlem is
correct
a TRAI ceremonial chamber is called
Kiva's were a feature of pre-columbian
structures in North America built by the
ancestral Puebloans Kiva's can be found
in what Canyon that shares its name with
a National Historical Park in
northwestern New Mexico Chaco Canyon
Chaco Canyon is correct
Ashlin each year Mardi Gras celebrations
draw thousands of revelers to public
spaces throughout New Orleans including
Bourbon Street and Jackson Square in
what district that is the city's oldest
French Quarter French Quarter is correct
Mashal formed by the eruption of Mount
Mazama some 7,000 years ago this lake in
Oregon was held sacred by the local
Klamath people and is the main feature
of a national park named this Lake
Crater Lake Crater Lake is correct
johnathan mission concepción built in
1755 was one of several Spanish missions
established to protect borders from
French encroachment and to convert
Native Americans to Catholicism these
missions are near what River that shares
its name with a large Texas City the San
Antonio River that is correct
Shawn Native Americans in north-central
Wyoming have long used this stone
medicine wheel for ceremonies and to
predict astronomical events this sacred
site is a national landmark in what
mountain range that is a source of the
Powder River the Absaroka Range I'm
sorry we were looking for Bighorn
Mountains three rounds down four more to
go before we say goodbye to the students
with the four lowest scores
but with eight points up for grabs it's
still anyone's game now before we dive
back into the competition let's get to
know a little bit more about our ten
fine finalists Nihar let's begin with
you you are also the winner of the 2016
Scripps National Spelling Bee that is
very impressive
can you spell my first name in French
em oh I'm sorry it's MEA you will settle
it later with the score vein cut Ranjan
you're from San Ramon California give me
sort of a fun fact about San Ramon like
maybe a point of interest what's the
best thing about it the headquarters of
the oil company Chevron that's all we
have a little company okay that you plan
on taking over maybe once you leave here
and it's a great place to live right
yeah okay you gonna work for the Chamber
of Commerce Gayatri
it says here that you went snorkeling in
Hawaii and had a family of dolphins swim
right next to the boat how could you
tell they were a family well that's what
the tour guide said so I'm sorry what's
that that's what the tour guide said I
know but they could have been friends
just hanging out was it exciting hmm was
it exciting yeah yeah all right
excellent
sock age you are from Ohio and you won
the Ohio State gob three years in a row
where all the questions about Ohio no
okay right
what do you know that old song isn't
always it's round on the end and high in
the middle oh hi oh you have to be 49 or
older to get that
oops I gave it away so anushka it says
here this is really cool that you enjoy
reading fiction and plan on writing a
book about an explorer do you know which
explorer are you interested in I think
everything from the Renaissance and like
all the explorers coming to the new
world that's something that's really
interested me so I think that's an
interesting story concept okay
Oh interesting alright and and you've
played the violin for how long I think
six or seven years and how was it
balancing studying for this and playing
the violin or did one help the other in
a way it's a really good break a lot of
the time like if I'm studying it I'm
just not remembering stuff then it's
something I'll just go and do play for
an hour and then I'll be able to retain
much more information that way right I
love that she blows off steam by
studying the violin
how low do I feel that's it very
impressive it's gonna mess around and
get off that violin come on you're
wasting time so are a trio you are the
youngest one here how does it how does
that feel I mean you're I mean you're in
fifth grade it feels good to be like the
youngest one right like I have nothing
to lose
because you got time I mean you're gonna
survive all these people here you've got
years ahead of you right you yeah that's
a good point because you can just right
really sort of just have fun because you
got years to go with this eligibility
yeah and you really are just 11 this is
not a ruse yeah I'm 11 okay
our a Schwinn this is the second time
I've moderated with you up here you were
here two years ago yeah what happened
last year no kidding
no it's very very impressive that you're
here twice okay you were now you were
just recently traveling through Costa
Rica tell us about that
well it was really cool cuz unlike other
countries in Latin America Costa Rica
has really taken a lot of efforts to
preserve its biodiversity so we got to
travel through a lot of really pristine
rainforests and natural environments
that don't really exist anymore anywhere
else in Latin America so it's very
incredible well that's wonderful and
there's I think an election coming up
and Costa Rica and he should be on the
ballot Vishal you are from Georgia yeah
George has a lot of great crops yes so I
have to ask you the question peanuts or
peaches peaches that is correct for an
extra point it's a wonderful state that
it's a beautiful state all right
Jonathan from North Carolina Jonathan
song you were on a robotics team that
competes in the first tech challenge
what is that well it's like it's like
you make these like mini robots it's not
the full-size once but they compete on a
field and they do missions when you
eventually create your own robot what is
what is what is your priority what is
the one thing you want your robot to be
able to do if it could do anything
and I'm guessing Jonathan's parents feel
the same way all right Sean Chang from
New Hampshire
your hobbies include speed cubing and at
first when I read it I thought it was
speed clubbing and I thought you're a
little young for that so what is speed
cubing it's just solving like Rubik's
cubes as fast as you can
it specifically Rubik's cubes what calm
there's like different sized ones like
the traditional ones like a 3x3 but
there's different sizes and how fast can
you do sort of an old-fashioned rubik's
cube um my best competition time is nine
point two nine seconds nine point two
seconds yeah oh my gosh that's Wow
how long it takes me to make the first
turn oh and I'm red so it is it do you
know what the state fruit of New
Hampshire is no all right well it's in
the final round
no I'm kidding all right it's a pumpkin
I thought that that was kind of cute and
confusing because I thought a pumpkin
was just a decoration or maybe a
vegetable all right let's give a shout
out at this point to our other 44
finalists these brilliant students
and now back to our competition for
round four you'll need your stylus again
because everyone answers this question
at the same time this question is worth
one point the National Geographic
Society is committed to exploring and
protecting our planet and supporting
bold individuals who are pushing the
boundaries of knowledge take a look at
your monitors Daniella kavagi
is a biologist and National Geographic
young Explorer as a child in Mexico she
was attracted to strange and
misunderstood animals like spiders and
snakes today she is fortunate to work
with one of the most mysterious
creatures bats
Daniella's current project is to
identify and preserve bat species in
archeological zones so at night she
spends time inside pyramids looking for
these beautiful animals and here is your
question some female lessor long-nosed
bats migrate to the United States to
roost in a National Monument that
borders Mexico these bats are the
primary pollinators of a species of
cactus that gave its name to the
monument what is the name of this cactus
you will have 12 seconds to write down
your answer
time's up let's see what everyone wrote
for one point the correct answer is
organ pipe okay so let's see how
everyone did three of you had the
correct answer I was a nail-biter there
we've come to the first geo challenge of
the competition we'll be testing you not
just on what you know but how well you
know it each of you will be presented
with a different map of the contiguous
United States and two choices for what
that map is showing you will have ten
seconds to tell us your answer if you
are correct you will receive one point
and the opportunity to explain why for a
possible two additional points we will
give you a few moments to think about
your response and when the bell rings
you'll have twenty seconds in which to
complete your explanation a panel of
judges will determine if your
explanation is strong enough to earn the
additional two points when it's your
turn take a look at your monitor ready
me heart take a look at your map does
this map show vegetation zones or
average wind speeds this map is showing
vegetation zones I'm sorry the correct
answer is average wind speeds so
unfortunately you don't get any points
vayne cut take a look at your map does
this map show irrigated land or peach
production this map shows irrigated land
that is correct for one point for two
additional points tell us why this
answer is correct this map is showing
irrigated land because areas that do not
naturally receive a lot of water that
support farming are shown in the map
like the Central Valley of California
and the Snake River Valley of Idaho this
map cannot be a peach production map
because most peaches are grown in the
south especially in Georgia all right
and we're gonna give the judges a moment
to confer and the judges are quite
satisfied with your answer so two
additional
for you Gayatri take a look at your map
does this map show percent of federal
land or miles driven per capita
this map shows miles driven per capita
that is correct for one point for two
additional points tell us why this
answer is correct had this map shown
percent of federal land places like
Arizona and New Mexico with lots of land
owned federally by the government would
have had a higher shading
this map shows miles driven per capita
because open places like Wyoming and
Montana have give the judges a moment to
confer and you just got those two
additional points for your answer for
your explanation socket does your map
show average minimum wage or ferryboat
boardings by state this map shows
average minimum wage I'm sorry that is
incorrect the correct answer is very
boat boardings by state so no points for
you
anooshka does your map show pesticide
use or number of dairy cows its map
shows pesticide use pesticide use is
correct you're in one point for two
additional points tell us why this
answer is correct
this map shows pesticide use because the
highest concentrations are in the Great
Plains and along the Mississippi River
where a lot of pesticides are used in
farming if this map was showing number
of dairy cows there would be a much
higher concentration in Wisconsin and
Texas we'll give the judges a moment to
confer
and Anushka they like your answers or
two additional points for you at Raya
take a look at your map and tell us does
it show
percent homeless or literacy rate what
is your rate I'm sorry at Raya the
incorrect answer is percent homeless
Ashwin
does your map show the range of the
Blackbear or the range of the ponderosa
pine range of the ponderosa pine that is
correct
and for one point for two additional
points tell us why this answer is
correct
this map shows range of the ponderosa
pine because all of the coloring is in
the western United States where the
range of the ponderosa pine is in the
interior West it doesn't show black bear
because black bears are also found in
the eastern United States judges what
say you the judges like that answer two
additional points for ashlynn Vishal
just your map show number of days with
freezing temperatures or average annual
snowfall average annual snowfall it is
average annual snowfall for one point
for two additional points tell us why
your answer is correct
this map shows average annual snowfall
because area such as the Colorado
Rockies and the Sierra Nevada have a
high concentration in this map and this
map does not show freezing temperatures
because there would be a higher
concentration in areas such as north
like Western North Carolina and eastern
Tennessee where there would be more
freezing temperatures the judge is
approve of the shawls explanation for
two additional points Jonathan take a
look at your map does this map show
public libraries or golf courses public
libraries public libraries is correct
your honor to additional points tell us
why this answer is correct
this map shows public libraries because
the higher concentration on this map is
in the cities where the majority of
public libraries are located it doesn't
show golf courses because golf courses
can also be found in rural and silver
in areas judges the judges like that
answer to additional points to Jonathan
Shawn does your map show Superfund
hazardous waste sites or four-year
colleges four-year colleges I'm sorry
the correct answer was Superfund
hazardous waste sites and that concludes
the first geo challenge round five
rounds down and two more to go before
our first four eliminations there are
four points up for grabs
over the next two rounds you'll need
your stylus again in round six we'll be
hearing from a National Geographic
Explorer take a look at your monitors hi
I'm Courtney Bergersen I am an
anthropologist a conservation biologist
and a National Geographic Explorer
you'll often find me in Madagascar where
I study ecosystem balance and the
illegal hunting of endangered lemurs but
I'm also passionate about education and
I visit classrooms in the u.s. to teach
students about scientific inquiry right
in their own backyards now here's your
question
one of my first experiences with science
was a school field trip to a u.s. island
that is home to the world's
longest-running predator-prey study this
lake island is now overpopulated with
moose and scientists want to bring the
island back into ecological balance by
repopulating it with wolves named this
lake island which is also a national
park we'll have 12 seconds to write down
your answer
time's up let's see what everyone wrote
for one point the correct answer is all
together now Isle Royale now let's take
a moment to review the scores before our
next round Ashwin is in front and there
is a five-way tie bang cut Gayatri
anushka vishal and jonathan right behind
there okay after this round the four
students with the lowest scores will
leave us but there are still three
points up for grabs for each student in
round seven the aptly named lightning
round here's how it works I'll give you
each I'll give each of you three
questions in a row and you'll have six
seconds to answer each one point is
awarded for each correct response get
ready this one moves like like lightning
I'll work on my delivery okay here we go
Neha what is the name of the largest
swamp on the border of Virginia and
North Carolina the Great Dismal Swamp
that is correct
and again Nihar why'm a a canyon is
located on which Hawaiian island Kauai
that is correct
name the state reptile of Mississippi
alligator the American alligator that is
correct
bang cut name the oldest existing
national park east of the Mississippi
River Acadia that is correct
again been cut name the widest falls
section at Niagara Falls Horseshoe Falls
Horseshoe Falls is correct settlers in
Oklahoma who started the land rush early
inspired what nickname for the state the
Sooner State that is correct
dietary what large city in eastern
Tennessee was the state's first capital
Memphis I'm sorry the answer is
Knoxville again to gayatri Providence
Rhode Island is located at the head of
what Bay the Narragansett Bay that is
correct
what is Washington State's most valuable
food crop in terms of total revenue
apples apples is correct socket name the
highest mountain peak in Vermont Mount
Mansfield that is correct
what is the largest island of American
Samoa to to ela to two wheelers correct
what fruit is on the standard Florida
license plate in orange the orange is
correct
anooshka named the rift Lake on the San
Andreas Fault that is the largest lake
in California the Salton Sea Salton Sea
is correct name the sub range of the
Rocky Mountains that marks the western
border of Montana the Bitterroot range
that is right what two and a half mile
walking route in Boston Massachusetts
connects 16 historic sites the Freedom
Trail the Freedom Trail is correct
a TRAI named the largest city on
Colorado's Cache la Poudre River Fort
Collins
Fort Collins is correct name the group
of islands in northern Wisconsin that
make up part of a National Lakeshore
apostille Islands
you got it what gift from France is
pictured on the State Quarter of New
York Statue of Liberty Statue of Liberty
is correct
Ashwin named the largest lake in Alaska
like Iliamna that is correct what River
forms most of the border between Texas
and Louisiana the Sabine River the
Sabine River is correct what is the
official dance of the state of Hawaii
who uh who less correct Vishal
what Bay is the sunken estuary of the
Susquehanna River Chesapeake Bay that's
correct
name the largest city on the Cuyahoga
River Cleveland Cleveland is correct
what is the popular name for the group
of stars depicted on Alaska State Flag
the Big Dipper the Big Dipper is right
Jonathan
name the highest mountain peak in
California Mount Whitney you got it
named the capital of Guam could you name
the capital of Guam sorry Agana that is
acceptable yes forgot huh got Mia Oregon
ah that's correct
what is the official crustacean of
Louisiana the crawfish that is correct
Shawn what a North Carolina city is
located at the confluence of the
Swannanoa River and the French Broad
River Charlotte I'm sorry the answer is
Asheville named the largest lake in
Maine which is the source of a can aback
river Meuse head lake that is correct
in 1812 soldiers from Tennessee inspired
what nickname
for the state the Volunteer State the
Volunteer State is corrrect that
deserves a round of applause I'm winded
now we have reached the conclusion of
part one of the competition and we now
have the tough task of saying goodbye to
atreya Nihar stockade and Shawn a huge
round of applause valiant competitors
here one of these six students will be
named the xxx champion of the National
Geographic Bee remember there's a lot on
the line for these finalists including
$85,000 in scholarship money now you may
not know this or maybe you do but I love
geography and we thought it would be fun
to turn the tables and have the students
quiz me on their home states so hit me
with your best shot we'll start up here
Bankhead named the smallest county by
area in California you know I bet I bet
because their whole lot of people packed
in there I bet it's Los Angeles County
No okay then I phat was not Orange
County I bet it's oh it's San Francisco
its own County yes okay so it's it's the
San Francisco County at the Concetta
what's that
good job okay all right well I sort of
got that how small is it I don't know
just
well we're even that Gayatri
what is the Indian Reservation located
inside an Indian Reservation an Indian
Reservation inside of an Indian
Reservation it's an Indian Reservation
side of oh it's the turducken nation and
you don't say I'm wrong that I'm right
what is it called do you want the answer
well I mean at this point I think we
might as well resolve that okay
it's the Hopi or the Hopi what are they
inside of the Navajo oh my god that must
be so suffocating well we learn
something every day you moderate the
National Geographic Bee Anushka I Love
New Jersey and I just before you ask me
anything I just want everyone to know
that New Jersey has the most diners in
America and that is true this one's
really hard okay okay what's the highest
point in New Jersey what's the highest
point in what's the highest the highest
point in New Jersey and it's not Trenton
it's a New York is there there's got to
be a mountain in New Jersey Mount
Soprano what is it it's called High
Point
[Applause]
that is such a dad joke after the
explorer book you got to write a book of
one-liners that's great I like that I
Love New Jersey New Jersey also has the
most scientists and engineers per square
mile
okay
Ashwin name the westernmost point in
Oregon the what the westernmost point oh
the Pacific Ocean I know the westernmost
point is there I once went to Pacific
City Oregon oh I'm sure there's some
dude in Portland that has a houseboat
that's sort of like drifted out to sea
so far he forgot where he was and I was
thinking of Cape Blanco but you were
actually correct with the Pacific Ocean
I know how to game the system I should
be there vishal asked me about georgia
the University of Georgia's look in
which city north east of Atlanta Athens
yeah that was this this is the way it
should go every time Jonathan let's ask
me about North I love North Carolina I'd
spent two summers in winston-salem what
city was created in 1913 by the merging
of two major tobacco towns Oh
winston-salem and now back to the game
from this part of the competition on
we're going global questions are now
worth two points and after six more
rounds the three remaining students with
the lowest scores will be eliminated
let's move on to round eight this round
will require spoken answers only I'm
going to give you each a question to
test your knowledge and recognition of
national capitals when it's your turn a
photo related to your question will
appear on your monitor you will have 12
seconds to answer I'm beginning with
venca once a Viking settlement this
capital city is located on the east
coast of an island where the River
Liffey enters the sea named this city
Dublin Dublin is correct
dietary this capital city is home to the
Grand Palace which was once the official
residence of the kings of Siam named
this city bangkok bangkok is correct
Anushka in 2011 Tahrir Square was the
focal point of a revolution in a capital
city named this city which is located
between the ruins of the ancient city of
Memphis and one of the world's major
river deltas Cairo Cairo is correct
Ashlin southwest of the highest point in
the Andes Mountains this capital city is
located on the Maputo River in a
geological zone prone to earthquakes
name this city Santiago Santiago is
correct
Vishal founded by the Spanish this
capital city was supported by Soviet
subsidies for much of the second half of
the 20th century named this city located
along the Straits of Florida
Havana's correct Jonathan this capital
city is located northwest of the
Cyclades on a peninsula that borders the
Aegean Sea named this city which was
once a powerful city-state Athens Athens
is correct no time to waste let's get
right to round nine for this next
question you'll need your stylus once
again we
another special guests take a look at
your monitors hi I'm grace kahlert young
an ocean engineer Aquanaut and National
Geographic the emerging Explorer I've
lived at the bottom of the ocean in the
Florida Keys
sailed across the Atlantic Ocean and
I've worked with NASA to create 3d maps
of asteroids right now I'm working to
refurbish a submarine in Kansas of all
places my great passion though is
connecting art with science for example
by creating 3d maps of coral reefs and
dancing underwater
now here's your question my research has
taken me to the coral reefs off the
island of Utila utila is the westernmost
island of what archipelago off the coast
of Honduras we'll have 12 seconds to
write down your answer
time's up let's see what everyone wrote
for two points the correct answer is Bay
Islands let's see how you did three of
you had the correct answer students
please keep your stylus out for this
next video question this year National
Geographic the Audubon Society birdlife
international and Cornell Lab of
Ornithology are joining with nature
lovers around the world to celebrate the
year of the bird birds symbolize
nature's interconnectedness and our next
special guest is raising awareness of
the importance of protecting birds in a
changing world once again take a look at
your monitors hi i'm washington wa Shira
my life conservationist in a National
Geographic Explorer I study African
ground eagles in urban environments
I found them nesting near buildings but
they prefer forested parks with
indigenous trees unfortunately many
facts are threatened by human activity
and development so I work to increase
public awareness on ways people and
birds can share urban spaces now
here's your question African crown
Eagles can be found in forests in a
capital city near the at the river named
this city which is sometimes called the
green city in the Sun we'll have 12
seconds to write down your answer
time's up let's see what everyone wrote
for another two points the correct
answer is Nairobi back row there all had
it correct
in this next round I'm going to give
each of you a question inspired by the
National Geographic Channel series
called one strange rock which explores a
fragility and wonder of planet Earth a
photo related to your question will
appear on your monitor you will have 12
seconds to answer Bank cut in northern
Quebec the penguin crater is an example
of how meteorites have shaped our planet
pink Willick crater is located on what
large Peninsula south of the Hudson
Strait the Ungava Peninsula the Ungava
peninsula is correct
Gayatri the convergence of three
tectonic plates created this depression
where the ground spits acid located in
the northern part of the afar region on
the Horn of Africa what is the name of
this feature the Danakil depression the
Donna kill depression is correct
anooshka around the world water is
temporarily harnessed by tens of
thousands of large dams
such as the shall Lang D dam in Henan
Province the shall lanky dam is located
on what river north of the Qinling
mountains the Yellow River is correct
Ashwin millions of years ago super
volcanoes set off an instinctive en't
that killed most of life on earth
protected in its underground burrows a
reptile called throne accident survived
fossils of this species have been found
near what river that rises in the
Lesotho Highlands and flows through
uppington the orange river the orange
rivers correct the shawl covering over
5% of Earth's landmass lichens
such as these on islands and Ontario
break down rocks generate oxygen and
absorb pollute
these islands can be found in what Bay
east of the Bruce Peninsula Georgian Bay
the Georgian Bay is correct Jonathan on
the tow jian islands in the gulf of
tomini most children learn to swim
before they can walk the gulf of tomini
is one of three gulfs that define the
unique shape of which of the greater
sunda islands Sulawesi Sulawesi is
correct for this next question you'll
need your stylus again for a question
from a special repeat guest who visited
us last year from Kazakhstan take a look
at your monitors hello my name is Paul
Salopek and I'm a journalist in National
Geographic fellow and I'm 1,500 miles
further along on my 21,000 mile out of
Eden walk I'm following the pathways of
our ancestors who migrated Africa 60,000
years ago writing about topics such as
climate change - migration -
technological innovation and you can
follow along on this 10-year journey at
w WAW
my walk will take me to a city in India
renowned for its architecture and urban
design it was declared a Union Territory
in 1966 and serves as the joint capital
of two neighboring states named this
city you will have 12 seconds to write
down your answer
time's up let's see what everyone wrote
for two points the correct answer is
chunda Garr see how you all did four of
you had it right 12 rounds down and one
more to go before we have to say goodbye
to the three students with the lowest
scores so let's take a look at the
current standings Bank cut and Anushka
are tied in first place vishal is not
far behind
six points though are still up for grabs
in our second and final lightning round
once again when it's your turn you'll be
asked three questions in a row and have
six seconds to answer each this time
you'll receive two points for each
correct response a lot at stake there's
a lot of room to make up ground kids
okay students are you ready
Vanka name the largest of the Balearic
Islands Majorca my orcas
the Salween River flows into the Gulf of
March a van before entering what see
this is for you've anchored the Andaman
Sea that is correct what religion is
practiced by a majority of the people in
Mongolia Buddhism Buddhism is correction
Gayatri the Far East of Bolivia is part
of what large tropical wetland the grand
Chaco I'm sorry the answer is the
Pantanal name Sweden's largest island
Gotland Gotland is correct what is the
official working language of the federal
government of Ethiopia Amharic Amharic
is correct Anushka
what channel connects Baffin Bay with
the Beaufort Sea
the Perry channel Perry channels correct
what is the name of the highest mountain
peak in Algeria not too hot
you've got it what is the predominant
religion of Mauritius Hinduism Hinduism
is correct
Ashwin what large salt water lake is
located just west of Tabriz Iran liquor
mia lake or Mia's correct name the Gulf
on the southern coast of Honduras Gulf
of Fonseca the Gulf of Fonseca is
correct what is the official language of
Mozambique Portuguese Portuguese is
correct
Vishal name the southernmost state of
Mexico
Oaxaca the answer I'm sorry is Chiapas
what man-made lake spans one-third of
the border of Zambia and Zimbabwe Lake
Kariba Lake Kariba is correct what is
the official currency of Denmark the
Krone the krona is correct
Jonathan what channel south of the Irish
Sea separates Wales from Ireland
the answer is st. George's Channel
Matsuyama is the largest city on what
major Japanese island Shikoku Shikoku is
correct what is the official language of
an Tora Catalan Catalan is correct
all right the time has come to bid
farewell to half of the students on
stage let's take a look at the scores we
must say goodbye now to Gayatri Ashwin
and Jonathan
here they are the final three
each of these three finalists has now
won at least a $10,000 scholarship so
big congratulations to each of you
you've already won big next we get one
step closer to crowning our champion as
these three students square off in the
final geo challenge round to learn more
about how your school can participate in
the 2019 National Geographic Bee visit
our website NatGeo beat org for details
and instructions on how to get started
maybe we'll see a student from your
hometown here next year we're ready to
continue with the 30th national
geographic be our three finalists are
sequestered backstage where they can
neither see nor hear anything happening
on stage in this next geo challenge
round we'll bring them out one by one to
test them not just on what they know but
how well they can apply and communicate
that knowledge each student will answer
the same question which poses a
real-world scenario and they'll be given
three possible answers from which to
choose our panel of judges will score
their responses based on three criteria
accuracy reasoning and presentation each
year millions of tons of plastic waste
end up in the oceans threatening
everything that depends on earth's
largest ecosystem National Geographic
has begun a multi-year effort to raise
awareness and help find solutions to
this crisis our three finalists will be
asked to identify a location for an
ongoing cleanup effort to recover
plastics from a local River the goal is
to reduce the amount of plastic that
reaches the ocean the students must tell
us which River is the best location and
why the students must focus their effort
at the mouth of one of three rivers the
nisha River the Rhine River or the
Yangtze River they must factor in the
area's population plastic consumption
and plastic waste management the Yangtze
River is the best choice because of the
high population and high plastic
consumption in the Yangtze River Basin
it's also a rapidly growing area with
overwhelmed waste management the nisha
River would be the second best choice
the region has less population and
plastic consumption than that of the
Yangtze though it's waste management is
also strained the Rhine River is the
weakest choice for the cleanup effort it
has the lowest population and while it
has high per capita plastic consumption
it has the strongest existing waste
management the students must choose the
answer that best fits a scenario and
explain their reasoning we will give
each of them a moment to think about it
but once the bell rings they'll have 45
seconds to respond if he or she falls
silent for more than five seconds their
time will be up this question is worth a
whopping 9 points so this is a game
making or game breaking moment for our
finalists the students have been briefed
on these rules but obviously not the
question and remember this is not just
about right or wrong this is also about
reasoning and the quality of
presentation we begin with the student
currently in third place
Vishal please come on out on stage to be
the first to answer this geo challenge
and that's gonna take right front and
center that's perfect right there
Vishal here's the question each year
millions of tons of plastic debris ends
up in the oceans much of it from rivers
your goal is to help reduce the amount
of plastic that reaches the oceans by
organizing a cleanup effort to remove
plastic from a major river you can focus
your cleanup effort near the mouth of
one of three rivers the nisha River the
Rhine River or the Yangtze River based
on the criteria of population plastic
consumption and plastic waste management
on which River would your cleanup effort
have the greatest impact you will have
15 seconds to think about your answer
when the bell rings please begin
I would focus my cleanup effort on the
Yangtze River because first of all the
Yangtze River has a really great
population with cities such as Shanghai
and Nanjing second of all there's a lot
of plastic consumption with China being
having one of the most plastic consuming
countries in the world and China doesn't
have the best plastic waste management
so a cleanup would really help clean up
the plastic on the Yangtze River the
Niger River on the other hand does not
have as much plastic consumption as the
Yangtze does and the Ryan River is
really good with plastic waste
management and plot it doesn't consume
as much plastic as the Yangtze River for
these reasons I would choose the Yangtze
River for my cleanup effort thank you
round of applause for vishal nicely done
to come back here if you would and i'm
gonna ask you to stand like right in
here Sutter okay all right now let's
bring out Anushka okay I know she's got
come on out I'm gonna ask you to stand
nice from the center there Anushka
here's the question each year millions
of tons of plastic debris ends up in the
oceans much of it from rivers your goal
is to help reduce the amount of plastic
that reaches the oceans by organizing a
cleanup effort to remove plastic from a
major river you can focus your cleanup
effort near the mouth of one of three
rivers the measure the Rhine River or
the Yangtze River based on the criteria
of population plastic consumption and
plastic waste management on which River
which are cleanup effort have the
greatest impact you will have 15 seconds
to think about your answer when the bell
rings please begin
I would choose the Yangtze River to
focus a cleanup effort on the Yangtze
River float the mouth of the Yangtze
River is at Shanghai which is a major
city in China between between the many
people in this city there is a lot of
plastic waste that occurs and China is
often considered one of the most
populated places and populated and
polluted places in the world on the
other hand the Rhine River mouth is in
the Netherlands where there is a stable
cleanup system already in place and a
much smaller population along the Niger
River there's also less plastic waste
being used for these reasons I would
choose the Yangtze River to focus a
cleanup effort on thank you if I can ask
you to come back here please and stand
to the left of a hut perfect all right
and now let's bring out vane cuts
our bank cut if you want to stand right
in front the center there here's the
question each year millions of tons of
plastic debris ends up in the oceans
much of it from rivers your goal is to
help reduce the amount of plastic that
reaches the oceans by organizing a
cleanup effort to remove plastic from a
major river you can focus your cleanup
effort near the mouth of one of three
rivers the Lygia River the Rhine River
or the Yangtze River based on the
criteria of population plastic
consumption and plastic waste management
on which River would your cleanup effort
have the greatest impact you will have
15 seconds to think about your answer
when the bell rings please begin
I believe that the Yangtze River is the
best river to focus on plastic cleanup
effort on this is because tens of
millions of people live on think these
were very big and they produce a lot of
plastic as the as thanks to your Virgin
China has a huge manufacturing industry
that produced a lot of plastic waste
also the China does not have a very good
plastic waste management program unlike
the Rhine River in Europe and the Rhine
River is not a good choice because even
though it produces a lot of plastic as I
said before it does not has good plastic
waste management the Nazir River is not
a good choice because not too many
people live along its banks and it has
very low plastic consumption that is why
all right come with me please and if you
would bang cut in to the left and vishal
all the way on the right and anushka
between and the order in which you came
out great job by all of our finalists
now our judges will take a few moments
to confer
[Music]
the judges have tabulated the scores for
this geo challenge and are ready to
share the results judges will start with
Vishal hi Vishal you responded with the
Yangtze River which was the best choice
you gave great supporting facts for all
the criteria we were looking for
including mentioning Shanghai and
Nanjing your excellent presentation was
also very well organized and had an
excellent progression as well we gave
you eight points okay and that gives
Vishal a total now of 30 points and we
move on to a new canal Anushka you also
mentioned the Yangtze River which was
what we were looking for you had good
facts to support all of the criteria and
contrasted the weaker choices against
the best answer your presentation was
very very clear but it did feel a little
rushed we gave you seven points and that
gives Anushka total of 33 points and
finally then cut thanked it you also
mentioned the Yangtze River you had
excellent details and a more complete
explanation to support your choice
including mentioning the industrial base
of the Yangtze Basin your presentation
was effective but overall could have
been smoother we gave you eight points I
guess you think a total of 34 tremendous
job by all that was a real nail-biter
and after tabulating the scores we must
say goodbye to Vishal but don't forget
you're still leaving here a winner
there's a $10,000 scholarship with your
name on it a big congratulations to you
for making it this far
and then there were two Anushka buddha
code from new jersey and bang cut Ranjan
from california we are gonna get set up
for the final round and when we return
one of these gifted students will become
the 2018 National Geographic Bee
champion there is a lot on the line for
these students the champion will receive
a fifty thousand dollar scholarship plus
a lifetime membership to the National
Geographic Society and a Lindblad
expedition to the Galapagos Islands
aboard the National Geographic endeavor
- now back to maraca welcome to the
championship round of the 30th the
National Geographic Bee
out of 2.6 million students 54 the
country's brightest young geographers
made it here to Washington DC the top
ten earned their place to compete today
and now we're down to two 13 year-old
vane cut Ranjan from California and
thirteen-year-old Anushka Buddha Cote
from New Jersey congratulations to you
both on making it this far
so vane cut what would it mean to you to
win this thing good be good you're sort
of under playing it right now right
maybe I get it okay Anushka
how long have you prepared for this
moment I've been participating in the
National Geographic Bee since I was in
fourth grade since you were fourth grade
about nine or ten years eight or nine
years old right you know well excellent
okay well you've come a long way both of
you and now it's time to get down to
business here's how it's going to work
you each begin this final round with a
clean slate the championship round is
single elimination you will both be
asked the same question at the same time
the contestant who correctly answers a
question that the other contestant
misses will be named our national
champion so watch closely because every
question could be the winning question
you're gonna need your stylus for this
final round I will read each question
twice so listen carefully before
answering you'll then have 12 seconds to
write your responses for the final time
students are you ready they're ready
here is your question
name the small Southeast Asian country
that has a northern coastline on the way
tar and owned by straits
I repeat name the small Southeast Asian
country that has a northern coastline on
the way tar and owned by straits
bang cut what do you have East Timor
Yoshika Timor Leste the correct answer
is Timor Leste it also East Timor so you
are both correct and we like variety
okay on to the next question
Lebanon has a population most similar to
which South American country I repeat
Lebanon has a population most similar to
which South American country
then cut what do you have Paraguay
anooshka Guyana do you have two
different answers I can tell you now
that one is correct so we're about to
learn who is the 2018 National
Geographic Bee champion the correct
answer is Paraguay so Bangkok Ranjan is
the 2018 National Geographic Bee
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a dramatic end to a terrific competition
here's how our 10 finalists officially
finished and remember each of these
students outlasted millions of others
around the country to make it to
Washington DC and end up on this stage
and now to award the medals to our top
three finishers please welcome Mike
ulica interim president and CEO of the
National Geographic Society thank you
Mike finishing in third place and winner
of a $10,000 scholarship the shawls are
ready from Georgia wonderful
I will runner-up and winner of a $25,000
scholarship anushka buddha coat from new
jersey
and the winner of a 50,000 dollar
scholarship a lifetime membership to the
National Geographic Society in a trip
for 2 1 a Lindblad expedition to the
lump of those islands aboard the
National Geographic endeavor to the 2018
National Geographic champion
Venkata Ron John from California
thank you Mike and I'm gonna step over
here and Van Cod I've got to ask you
what was going through your mind on that
last question about the population of
Lebanon being similar most the most
similar to which South American country
I don't know this I have to guess
something so you kind of winged it kind
of right and we're lucky that in the
midst of those two minutes Paraguay
didn't have a huge baby boom or
something now please join me in
congratulating Bank OTT our other nine
finalists and all 54 of the students who
made it here to Washington DC I'm Mo
Rocca thanks for watching and remember
that science exploration education and
storytelling can change the world and I
want the parents of our three finalists
to come on up on stage let's get the
parents come on up
[Applause]
congratulations love it love it love it
[Applause]
[Music]